hello there hi Chris Traeger this is Ben
hello gents Ron Swanson Ron Swanson
okay I'm deputy director Leslie Knope
and Leslie Knope it was fantastic to be
here would you gentlemen like a tour oh
there is quite literally nothing I would
rather have in the world than a tour of
the Parks and Recreation Department of
the great city of Pawnee led by Ron
Swanson and Leslie Knope okay Ben I
don't think that's a great idea
Julie hey Chris is the most positive
state budget auditing consultant I've
ever met I mean I made eye contact with
him and it was like staring into the Sun
where's Chris I told him that one
headlight by The Wallflowers isn't
Dancing music and he said not with that
attitude
of course hey Ann what happened I just
saw you a few hours ago and you were
fine
not like damn you're fine but fine
health-wise my body has no fat to
protect itself from disease things
happen very quickly
listen to me it's very important that
you replenish my body with electrolytes
after every involuntary loss of bodily
fluids
my body since losing a lot of fluids
when it's sick my brain is on fire
I'm dying hmm well you definitely have
the flu
oh my god the microchip has been
compromised
I vomited somewhere in this room I don't
remember where though wait you might
want to check that drawer stop pooping
you have to get up off the floor now as
far as my friends nothing like a
complete physical breakdown to make a
guy seem less intimidating
I love the flu right now we have a class
to insanity emergency oh my god hey oh
my girls what's the emergency
oh this is just a drill but I'm having
so much fun pretending it's real not so
fast
I regret to inform you that someone in
this room has begun exhibiting symptoms
Christopher Trager what a few months ago
the thought of an infectious disease
even hypothetical would have sent me
careening towards bummer Ville but now I
am infected with the killer virus and I
feel fine therapy I'm afraid I have some
very bad news
hi Chris Traeger after several sustained
hours of diarrhea combined with violent
coughing and a devastating fever
followed by even more diarrhea have
succumbed to the avian flu I'm dead
Chris I'm dying I was dying earlier
today and then I died no I'm dead April
you are very intelligent and savvy young
woman I do not think of you as just a
gofer but right now I need you to get me
a triple espresso with eight sugars okay
what I'm on it I'll go I'm going please
I can go I don't mind it's better than
listening to a stump speech for a
millionth time no I will do it I have to
do it I need to do it goodbye this has
been a difficult year for me
romantically Millicent gergich in
Perkins Andy's professor that's a
disappointment
but if I keep my body moving and my mind
occupied at all times I will avoid
falling into a bottomless pit of despair
Oh Lizzie Lizzie welcome welcome welcome
I have a lot of bottles there oh yeah
would you like a vitamin b12 evening
primrose oil willow bark magnesium No
thank you sure you're the good for
hangovers okay I'll take one
I take care of my body above all else
diet exercise supplements positive
thinking scientists believe that the
first human being who will live 150
years has already been born I believe I
am that human being
Tom I have something I need to talk to
you about do we need to sit like this
yes Mona Lisa's taking advantage of you
and I'm sure that it's not easy when
it's the sister of a dear friend oh no
it's not that she scares the crap out of
me I once saw her punch a police horse
in the face speak directly to her and
tell her I will not be disrespected
you're Tom Haverford you're a smart
successful young man with an adorable
little belly stand up for yourself yeah
I'll talk to her before the party but if
she murders me tell John Ralphie Oh to
clear my browser history thanks for the
advice man welcome son
was that nothing
and brigade's hey Chris gotta run to a
meeting with Ron great idea I'll run to
my next meeting
Donna there's trouble a-brewin we think
that you may have accidentally tweeted
from the Parks and Rec account rather
than your own personal account Oh
what'd it say see you tonight hope you
like tongue baths you big nasty fireman
then there's a picture of a pair of lips
and then a picture of an eggplant I'm
both confused and if we're being totally
honest a little aroused no Jim is trying
to use this to hurt me in the recall
he's trying to take me down he's willing
to attack my friends in the process no
no way not on my way not in her wife he
is not gonna Sully your name no sawing
allowed don't worry about it Donna we're
gonna nip this in the bud guard your
buds because I'm about to get next okay
okay thank you for the woodworking
lesson run this whole crib recall things
got me literally rethinking everything I
thought I knew about parenting what's
the method will you be using Ferber
Sears Swanson method where you close
your eyes and fall asleep
I really wish Ron would engage but he
exudes so much wisdom that I can learn
parenting tips simply by being in his
presence someone like Ron is teaching
even when they're not teaching does that
make sense
my anxiety has kept me up for over 50
hours they have to come up with some
solution for this lug problem some of
there's a slug infestation boy oh boy we
live interesting lives filled with
unexpected challenges life is precious
and every day is a miracle okay
freak hey Jerry I didn't know you were
working today yeah Ryan asked me to come
in while he's away of course I had to
cancel my cardiologist deploy that's
great
now here's a piece of information that
is interesting Ana's pregnant and it's
my baby oh that's wonderful news
oh there's so much in front of you I
mean soon you're gonna start showing and
then your clothes will feel tight and
then oh people are gonna start rubbing
your tummy all the time
that sounds terrible well Gayle she got
really queasy and I gained a lot of
sympathy weight yeah you know actually
before my kids I looked a lot like you
Chris I'm very sad they stopped talking
I've been reading up on nipples the
reason that you're feeling nipple
sensitivity is because your milk ducts
in your nipples aren't opening up which
is why I bought you this knit one get it
some kernston's the nipple people it has
nipple cream nipple pads and also a
special nipple pimp appointment in case
you develop any pimples on your nipples
oh my god you have to stop using the
word nipple anyway hopefully that will
help you with any sensitivity that may
arise around your boob hats happy
Valentine's Day Pawnee for me it is not
happy but don't let my sadness diminish
your night anyway life is fleeting
hey Chris what do you think about
changing the music sure hmm the joy that
I am feeling right now is profound and
unmatched in the modern era and and I
can't tell you what it means to me that
I'm the very first person that you chose
to tell oh let me walk around with you
as you tell everyone else so that I can
share true joy being spread please
everyone we have something very exciting
to tell you that you have never heard
before Ben and I are engaged and you're
hearing about it for the very first time
right now what's going on listen better
engage again hey you're right man
the toast that you gave to Ben and
Leslie we're so beautiful
and I'm feeling very raw from my therapy
I'm like a perfect storm of emotions and
I'm hiding out here so I don't ruin this
party from my two amazing best friends
who I love so much this is the best
possible job for me I can literally make
anything sound positive your house just
burned down and you lost all your money
in the stock market it's a chance to
start over
fire is cleansing and true wealth is
measured by the amount of love in your
life if I had to have anybody tell me
that I had cancer I would want it to be
me you wanted to see me
good god what the hell are you doing
upside-down situps
great exercise and it literally lets me
see the world from a different
perspective
isn't there a men's gymnasium where you
could do that the museum Ross
you